dendritic cells are part of innate  immune system  they are potent phagocytes that mean  they engulf bacteria or any pathogen in  their way they are certified antigen  presenting cells that means after  engulfing a bacteria let's say they  would present all the bacterial proteins  or signatures onto a Class 2 MHC  molecule  and they can also secrete inflammatory  cytokines and bringing more immune cells  into the area of infection  they also secrete chemokines  these dendritic cell present their  antigens  onto a Class 2 MHC and present them to a  tease helper cell and thereby activate T  helper cell overall dendritic cell plays  a huge role in the immune response  subscribe for more and watch